le blindé de demain officiellement
présenté à versailles la ministre des
armées florence pas réalité ce mercredi
4 juillet sur le plateau de satory pour
réceptionner les six premiers griffon à
véhicule clé du programme scorpion qui
renouvelle la gamme de l'armée de terre
le véhicule griffon qui est un véhicule
qui a vocation à remplacer les v abe les
véhicules de l'avant blindés qui ont
rendu de très bons et loyaux services à
nos armées qui ont maintenant près de 40
ans et qui sont prêts si je puis dire de
de la retraite les véhicules multi rôles
servira notamment transporter des
troupes l'engin a été conçu en partie
dans l'entreprise nexter sur le plateau
de satory un site qui regroupe plus de
1000 collaborateurs
ici à versailles nous avons la direction
générale de la société le bureau
d'études qui travaille depuis des années
sur la conception de ces véhicules ainsi
que les services achats soutien et
différents services de la direction
générale donc le sait véritablement la
tête de nexter qui est ici même si les
usines se trouvent dans différents
départements français au total près de
1900 véhicule de type griffon seront
livrés d'ici 2030 le blindé sera utilisé
dans un premier temps dans la formation
des militaires il sera déployé sur le
terrain à partir de 2021